hello all minions troopers of the
glorious Empire have a glorious Empire
obviously I'm kneeling down in front of
my laptop in a place that is not my
fault my place is not this nice
yeah I'm not at home right now I am out
and about I knew I wasn't gonna be home
and of course the Doctor Strange trailer
had to happen so I'm gonna watch the
trailer I'm not gonna do a trailer
reaction as it happens but I am going to
watch it because I don't want to crop
copyright claim I mean I could probably
fight it and win I just don't want to
deal with it so I'll watch it and then
we'll talk about it and I'll talk about
what I saw when I'm out and about I
don't have my good camera we'll try to
make the best of it and I give you some
shitty camera quality and some
half-assed isn't the kind of decent
audio quality so alright let's watch the
Doctor Strange trailer that's awesome
but I want to see one part again so I'm
gonna go back right there I have that be
real quick yeah it's like this that
trailer was super super cool super
different it's like it doesn't feel like
a Marvel movie like it has well you know
the magic and then the fun it reminded
me more of Inception than anything and
what I love about it is there's no real
reference to Avengers I don't know if
it's gonna be in the movie or not it
could still be in the movie but it's an
origin story well first of all which is
always great because I love origin
stories but this is the origin story of
a guy who's gonna be so remarkably rad
let's do this sorcerer supreme this dude
is badass he's a powerhouse but he's not
yet it's his origin story really he
doesn't know and he's gonna learn
and that's really cool and it reminds it
it's like that Iron Man 1 vibe works
like this is pre Avenger this isn't
pretty Avengers I know that but since
there's no reference to Avengers it
feels the trailer makes you feel like
more of a self-contained origin story
and I think that's really really cool
and I don't want to see that now because
a lot of other things I mean by the time
we get a black
Panther movies like yeah he was in civil
war you know what else do you want but
that's really cool that it's more of a
detached origin story so they can have
the freedom to grill okay we don't have
to rely on the Avengers will just see
Cumberbatch being the batch of cumber we
all love with magic and I think that was
him talking and you know just just I
don't know how I'll subscribe other than
his American accent never heard him talk
like me it's well I don't want to
find out like now that was someone else
no I'm really looking forward to it
though I really am
this was it's one of those things where
the more set photos you see the more
costume photos you see of him the more
you're like this is the one I'm looking
forward to so yeah I can't wait to see
it but I'm only one in the equation of
the many and you've are all the many so
I want to know what you guys think about
it
so the Doctor Strange trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it was
everything you hoped it would be were
you hoping for something else I
personally love the magic inception vibe
I'm getting from this thing so I want to
see something new it looks like this
could be the most new of the Marvel
movies so we'll see what happens but
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more